[Applause]
George in a mismatch
Gobert that help comes and hang on the
benches there James the pace because
this is what happens you get a mismatch
you got Lou to go bear what he's 18 20
feet from the basket trying to guard
Paul George in result and an one for
Paul Jordan when he gets down to it they
they play iso basketball with Donovan
Mitchell off the screen from Adams
Westbrook rattles
six-point lead Billy Donovan and last
one hadn't even finished fallin Billy
was up fallin timeout Westbrook for the
half-dozen port tracked by George
Raymond Felton was checked in for the
Thunder he resets George who spins fires
and scores by Paul George he knew
exactly how much time was on the clock
and also putting himself with each
dribble you know I believe GPS said that
was from Lydia Oklahoma he stripped and
also putting himself with each Drupal
you know I believe GPS said that was
from Lydia Oklahoma he stripped seven
three-pointers in the quarter the Jazz
with an eight-point lead George trying
to respond and he does at the buzzer and
with their favorite play the two-man
game get the foul out of that Jerebko
switches Westbrook pulls up and still
negative eight point game at third
Utah shooting the two out of five in the
quarter
Westbrook is loaded into the weapons for
Josh uses to step out man he came in
gave the bugger submitter genic minutes
Westbrook rises fires at score six -
John second chances
George spins away from Engels katsumoto
step and small as it's a smart play
that's a tough shot just under 16
minutes to make up this big of a deficit
it starts with it not having any empty
possessions off the screen Westbrook
scores for free that is a career high
frame in three straight games now troll
helped the momentum off a place like
this Paul George back at that free throw
line with a chance for a three-point
play took the contact man he held onto
that basketball at the last couple years
in Turkey makes his presence felt like
he's reading a play right now I thought
there's a lot of contact on that drive
by Donovan Mitchell was way the screen
tonalities rush the scores again when
the brunt range that shot and all of a
sudden you ties lost its touch beyond
the arc leaving the door open for this
rally led by Russell Westbrook 10 to the
quarters to lead the charge and after
being down by as many as 25 just would
not give up it's on our side benefits
for free throws I spin move
it's really finished better in Italian
we down to 12 minutes
the shot clock violation
oh goodness ball chain just gets better
just dance the chef's get fitter
George has eight in the corner he
crosses over attacks let's go
can I tell you they made him vote for
that two points challenge to block
country roads
shot clock didn't reset thunders gonna
have to hurry Westbrook on the flop
boxcars for prey makes from beyond the
arc as part of that the challenge by
Mitchell the thunder of the stop George
out in front of the defense
and it's a one-possession game the
challenge by Adams just booked the three
[Music]
the way back from 25 points down as tool
14 Westbrook to the lead nose Adams and
westrom combining the [ __ ] - hi I
believe he has five personal five beg
your pardon you a director and a
favorites list here
let's go keep them on the [ __ ] jammer
and pulling the trigger beautiful screen
set by Adams Paul foods gonna print job
but go into the body but the beach for
the Jazz as well there's nobody there
home Russell Westbrook says I'll call my
own number on this one George
that's for us for three bang but a big
stop there for the Thunder
Westbrook glad to see that starts again
rush got 41 points you take that to live
by the three die by the three let's go
faster claps he scores and it's a
seven-point game punished extreme
[Applause]
over the top of Gobert George stepping
back and stars for trade
cold blooded from 25 points down in the
third quarter
Westbrook spotting up at scoring from
the elbow and Stephen Adams is happened
the game of his life in terms of setting
straight